[موسيقى]
اسديل الستار الذهبيه على مونديال العرب
في قطر الذي قالت عنه رئاسه الفيفا انه
افضل مونديال في التاريخ لتفيد دوحه
بوعدها بتنظيم بطوله استثنائيه في بلاد
العرب يقول الامير تميم بعد اتمام المهمه
انتهم مونديالنا بنجاح فاق المطلوب
والمرقوب وانتهت معه اوهام سوق الغرب لها
لعقود وعقود عقدت نفوس بعض ابنائنا حتى
صدقوا اننا امه عاجزه
المسلمون والعرب قادرون على الانجاز انجاز
تفويض العقول والهمم بالمهمات العظام
والمسلمون والعرب ليس نجاحهم مرهونا
بتحللهم من ثقافتهم وعقيدتهم بل ان قيمتهم
وخيريتهم في التاريخ تكمل في ساعه المعروف
والامساك عن اذى الناس للناس والمسلمون
والعرب اهل الفطره والفكره ليس في موروث
اجماعهم ما يخفى او يخيط والمسلمون والعرب
اهل كرم ونخوه وذوق وتقاليد يعيشونها بكل
فخر ويحترمون مشيئه الاخرين في تنظيم
مجتمعاتهم انتهم مونديالنا العربي الذهبي
ولم تشهد دوحه الامان فيه ضربه كف حتى
الرئيس ماكرون الذي لا يستطيع التجول في
فرنسا بدون حمايه كما يقولون
مسى بين الناس في سوق واقف وتجول في ملاعب
التحف الهندسيه ولم يرمى ببيضه واحده
اعتدى على ان يرشقه بها مرارا وبغيرها من
خضروات فاسده في شوارع باريس وساحاتها
انتهى مونديالنا العربي ذهبي وانتهت معه
نكته سامجه بان العرب اتفقوا على ان لا
يتفقوا فتبين ان الخلافه خلاف للسليقه
العربيه وان جليد السياسات والخصومات
ليصمدوا امام حراره الدماء والانتماء
انتهم ديالنا العربي الذهبي وانتهى معه
سراب التطبيع
بطبعاته الجديده والقديمه فدوله فلسطين حق
عربي ووقف اسلامي ومسيحي والوقف لا يوهب
ولا يباع انا سامي ومغاربي انا خليجي
ومصري انا تركي واندونيسي انا كل ذلك
واكثر واكثر من ذلك انا دمي فلسطيني
رددتها الجماهير في الدوحه فربحه القدس
كاس العالم
بنتيجه
مليارين صفر بشهاده الاعلام الاسرائيلي
وباصوات شعوب عربي والمسلمين الكلام عن
المونديال العربي الاسطوره لا ينتهي فاذا
اردتموني مخرج ان اسكت اذهبوا الى
العناوين
ايشادات بمونديال قطر افضل نسخه في تاريخ
كاس العالم
مونديال العرب في الدوحه افتتح بالقران
واختتم بالبشت العربيه
شهادات المشجعات الاجنبيات مونديال امن
بدون تحرش وسكارى
سخريه من دعوه حكومه الهند الى جلسه لمجلس
الامن حول الارهاب
هل وصف بوتين زعماء اوروبا
بانهم ممسحه اقدام للامريكيين
في تونس انتخابات بدون ناخبين فهل يصبح
الرئيس بدون مرؤوسين
الحطابون الاطفال هجروا مدارسهم وانتشروا
في جبال سوريا بحثا عن الدفء
مرحبا ان نقول ان فخرنا ودفاعنا عن
مونديال العرب في قطر في مواجهه الهجمه
الغربيه الشرسه هو دفاع عن ثقافتنا
الاسلاميه والعربيه وليست تلميعا لحكومه
بعينها قد يشكك البعض في مقاصد كلامنا
وهذا طبيعي فنحن نعيش ونعمل في قطر
وشهادتنا فيها مجروحه لكن سفيره باريس في
الدوحه
المتلبكه بلاده بالموقف من المونديال
الاخلاقي برغم دعوتها العالم الى رفع
القبعه للدوحه يصف قطر بالقوه الرائده في
المنطقه اما سفير الامبراطوريه الامريكيه
تيميدي فهو لا يحمل قبل ان يطبل به للعرب
لكن قبول الغرب انزعجت من وصفه قطر بانها
تقود طريقه تطور انا لا اظن فعلا بانه
يوجد بلد اخر في العالم يستطيع ان يبني ما
بناه القطريون في اخر 10 سنوات فقط ليس
فيما يخص ناطحات سحاب والمكاتب والمطاعم
فقط نحن نتحدث عن التكنولوجيا هنا كذلك
قطر فعلا تقود الطريق في المنطقه ولكن
كذلك حول العالم فيما يخص التكنولوجيا
وتطور واستعمال التكنولوجيا بهاتين
الشهاده
الرسميه الغربيه وفوقها شهادات اهل
الاغتصاب مونديال قطر هو افضل مونديال في
التاريخ هذا الكلام لا يقوله عصام الشوالي
من بي ان سبورت بل الاعلامي البريطاني
بيرس برجر فيما يؤكد رئيس الاتحاد الدولي
لكره القدم جيانا انفانتينو ان مونديال
قطر هو افضل نسخه من كاس العالم على
الاطلاق فهل ان قطر هي المنتصر الاخر في
كاس العالم
يسال الاعلام الاوروبي على مدى شهر كامل
واعيون العالم اجمع متجها نحو قطر البلد
الذي استقبل واحده من اكبر الفعاليات
العالميه والسؤال هل باتت الاماره
الخليجيه المنتصر الاخر في كاس العالم على
مستوى التنظيم سجل الحدث نجاحا كسهوله
الوصول الى الملاعب والاجواء الايجابيه
البعيده عن الفوضى بين المشجعين بالنسبه
للفرنسيين الذين تمكنوا من الحضور نجحت
قطر بكسب اعجابهم
ممتاز واستقبال حار
اريد ان اقول ان كل ما سمعناه عن القطريين
كان خاطئا قطري يلدعونا الى منزلهم انهم
رائعون العرب في الدوحه الذي افتتح
بالقران الكريم لاول مره في التاريخ اختتم
بالمشلح العربي البست وفي يوم قطر الوطني
امير قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد ال ثاني منح
نجم العالم المنتصر قائد منتخب الارجنتين
ليونيل ميسي الرداء العربي البيست او
المسلح مع ما يعنيه المشهد من التكريم في
لقطه سوف تخلد في تاريخ كؤوس العالم لكره
القدم
خسر المثليون ريهام على منتخب فرنسا بعد
ان وعدتهم وزيره الرياضه الفرنسيه املى
اودي كاستيرا برفع اشارتهم عند رفع كاس
العالم اذا فازت به ديوكو باريس لكن
الارجنتين ده جنه الديوك واستبدل علم
المثليين بالبشت رداء العرب الاصيل وقالت
شبكه روسيا اليوم انه تفاتي الجماهير
العربيه لا اله الا الله محمد رسول الله
هزت ارجاء استاد البيت ردا على اعتبار
مكروه الاساءه للرسول الكريم صلى الله
عليه وسلم
حريه الراي لكن مهلا مساءنا الرياضه
بالدين وبالسياسه يسال سائل فيجيب جامد
بسؤال سيال ومسانه مكروه بكره القدم هل هو
اللاعب الثاني عشر في المنتخب ام انه رئيس
جمهوريه
وعلى نفس الموجه سؤال لماذا جنا جنون
الغرب واعلامه من تتويج بطل العالم ميسي
بالبست العربي من المانيا وفرنسا وعمومي
اوروبا وحتى الولايات المتحده واسرائيل
غضب وصف بالعنصري وفي برلين وصف بالنازي
ووصل باحدى القنوات هناك الى وصف مشهد
البشت العربي بانه افساد لحظه تاريخيه
فيما صرح اخرون بانهم شعروا بالم في
المعده اثناء مشاهدتهم ميسي بلبيسط علاجهم
هو ارتداء البشت معصوب كاس من شاي الكرك
العربي بعضهم سوى قال فكره رفضه بان
البشته غطى القميص الارجنتيني الذي لم
يحجب في الاساس بل بقي يا ظاهرا في الصور
والبست شفاف وميسي اكثر رمزيه للكره
الارجنتينيه من القميص يقول اخرون رحبوا
بهذا التبادل الثقافي البديع هل نمت سنه
بنلبسه ثيابكم وبعدها حكي بعنصريه بس
كبرته
ميسي سيبقى هذا البشت على تاريخيه في
تاريخ كره القدم اعظم لاعب مر في تاريخ
كره القدم على الاقل في 30 40 سنه الماضيه
اخر لقطه له يحمل فيها كاس العالم يرتدي
المشلح العربي
مسج مسج دخل التاريخ واللي يتنرفز
المتنرفزين الحساب الرسمي للاتحاد
الارجنتيني لكره القدم رد على المعترضين
فنشر صوره الامير تميم وهو يهدي ميسي
البشت القطري وعلق عليها حقا انه الملك
فيما رد المشجعون الارجنتينيون بارتداء
البشت بكثره في الدوحه
كسوه باليده مذيعاني من شبكه فوكس
الامريكيه كان مصر ريدي للغايه اثناء
ارتيدا ايهمازيا القطريه الكامل خلال
استضافه الرئيس التنفيذي لشبكه احب قطر
خليفه الهارون
[موسيقى]
الاسود يعبر عن الوقار والقوه ارتداؤه
العباءه الفضفاضه السوداء تجربه خاضتها من
الاردن العربيه
في حضن العالم باكمله
طريقه الرسوم
ليون ليست المدينه الفرنسيه الوحيده التي
شهدت اعمال شغب وعنف ليله خساره فرنسا وقد
تسبب الغاضبون بوقوع اضرار في الممتلكات
العامه
اذا كان هؤلاء الغاضبون في حاله سكر اثناء
موجه الفوضى المتنقله مشجع انجليزي قرر
اعاده التفكير في علاقته مع الكحول فقبل
مونديال قطر كان يعتبر ان السعاده مرتبطه
بتناول الكحول لكنه وجد في الدوحه اناسا
اكثر سعاده بينه بدونها خصوصا ان معظم
المشاجرات في بلاده يفتعلها السكارى
يقولوا ساره
غيابه التحرش الجنسي فضيله اضافيه في
مونديال قطر رافقت منع تناول الكحول الذي
يحول بعض المشجعين الى همجيين خطيرين عينه
عن شهادات مشجعات ومشجعين اجانب ودعوات
الى تعميم التجربه القطريه الصحيه على كل
ملاعب الرياضه في العالم
ده صوت بره رسمه
بي بوابه
سامسونج
التي تعرف عليها لاول مره خلال فتره
مونديال قطر ويعيد الى الاذهان اكتشاف
الجنود الحملات الصليبيه ظاهره الحمام
العربي اثناء غزوهم مناطق المسلمين فيعلن
هذا اليوتيوبر الاوروبي عن تاسيس التراس
الشطافه الاوروبي فاكتشف انه حاجه جميله
قوي ان الناس دول عندهم شطه فقط يا جماعه
بمونديال قطر تلهم الغرب يوتيوبر يثير
تفاعلا ويتساءل عن كيفيه نقلها لاوروبا
بيقول ايه ديفيد يا ريت يا جماعه الصوره
دي تتطبع على تيشرتات انا دلوقت
اقول ان انا مؤسس
التراس الشطافه
مكافحه الارهاب عالميا شعار ما يزال مبهما
ما عدا من وجود تعريف الامميه واضحا ومتفق
عليه للارهاب ومع ذلك لابد من الدعوه الى
مكافحه الارهاب لكن من الداعي الهند التي
تواجه حكومتها المتشدده الان قائمه كبيره
من الاتهامات بهذه الافه
وليش ما بتوحد الهند جهوده مع اسرائيل
والشباب لمواجهه الارهاب هيك هيك ما حدا
بيحاسب النهج العالمي لمكافحه الارهاب
وتبادل الاراء حول المبادئ وكيفيه المضيء
قدمان كان محور جلسه الايحاطه التي دعت
اليها الهند على المستوى الوزاري للبحث في
التهديدات الارهابيه القائمه والناشئه
والتي تتطلب اعتماد نهج جماعي متجدد
لمواجهه الارهاب الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان سبق ان دعى عبر المحافل الدوليه
الى وقف التنكيلي بالمسلمين في الهند
بخلفيات طائفيه عنصريه اننا ننزل
سليمان
علي الخامنائي يعتبروا ان الشعب الايراني
وشعوب الشرق الاوسط لن ترتاح الا بعد رحيل
النظام في ايران سلفستر
[موسيقى]
الاسيوكستانكو الصغير
كما فهمت
ريال مدريد
جديده جديده
[موسيقى]
انتخابات تشريعيه في تونس شهيده انتقادات
ومقاطعه غير مسبقه تمثلت في نسبه الاقبال
التي وصفت بالضعيفه وكانت منطلقا للمعارضه
التي تجمع اكثر من 15 حزبا لتحميل الرئيس
قيس سعيد مسؤليه ذلك ومطالبته بالتنحل
فوري عن منصبه وتنظيم انتخابات الرئاسيه
مبكرا في تونس اذا انتخابات
وربما قريبا رئيسا بدون مرؤوسين استجابه
لدعاء عادل امام على الشعب في مسرحيه
الزعيم
الشعوب كلها
فيهم عشان الرؤساء يصحوا الصبح ما لوش حد
يحكموه بقى في السودان لم يعد انقطاعوا
الكهرباء بحسب الوزراء فضيحه بل الفضيحه
في نظري وزير الماليه جبريل ابراهيم هو
الا يكون لدى المؤسسات مولدات كهرباء خاصه
تستغني بها عن كهرباء الدوله المقطوعه
الحادثه في السودان والحديث يشملها ويشمل
لبنان وسوريا والعراق واليمن على الاقل
وانت صديقي المشاهد اذا كنت تعاني من
انقطاع الكهرباء في مدينتك اخبرنا باسمها
واسمي بلدك لتوسيع المعرفه والفضيحه
الحكوميه
تحتيه المرتبطه بسلاسل الامداد الغذائيه
لا ادري ان كنتم ستسمعونني نعتذر همم هذا
همم
الخطا العرض
المراره اسم لشيئين
لاصق بكبد الانسان تختزن فيه الصفراء وهي
تساعد على هضم المواد الدهنيه رجل تركي
جمع بين المرارتين بل جمع في جوفه من
الحصى اكثر مما تختزنه مرار جميع الاتراك
ربما رقم لا يصدق لكنه حقيقه يقول الطبيب
والكاميرا
4,000 546
مرمره مرارته قبل استخراجه
[موسيقى]
تحيه السنه مع اقتراب نهايتها نرفعها لكل
اب او معيل ضاقت حيلته واتسع قلبه بالرجاء
يطوي الارض نهارا واحيانا في الليل ليطعم
عياله بعيدا عن اي سند رسمي في بريطانيا
يرتفع عدد الاسر التي باتت تعتمد على
وجبات المدارس المجانيه بتمويل حكوم
لاطعام اطفالهم ففي خضم الازمه الاقتصاديه
يواجه بعض الاباء صعوبه في دفع نحو جنيهين
ونصف جنيه الاسترليني لقاء حصوله ابنائهم
على وجبه غدا ويرتاد هذه المدرسه عدد كبير
من التلاميذ المتحدرين من اسر فقيره
ويستفيد قرابه نصف تلاميذها من وجبه
مجانيه في مقصدها بتمويل من الحكومه هل
سمعتم بحكايه الخطابين الاطفال عندما
يكونوا على اطفال العشر سنوات ان يهجر
مدارسهم الى الجبال بحث عن حطب للاشتعال
في مدفاه بدائيه بخيمه رقيقه تعاند الثلج
والمطر والصقيع فتلك جريمه بحق الطفوله
والانسانيه نتحمل مسؤوليتها جميعا اذا كنا
ما نزال نؤمن بان الشعب السوري المظلوم في
تغريبه النزوح جزء منا لا فضلا ولا منه
عمري 11 سنه والله
ما في المقابل هناك اطفال محظوظون في محيط
المدينه مصياف الموليه للنظام السوري
يرتدون المدارس لكنهم ينقلون اليها
بشاحنات نقل البضائع والاغنام لكن ليس
امامهم الا ان يتعلموا على امل نيل شهاده
تفتح لهم ابواب المغتربات
[موسيقى]
يا ويلكم من الله
ختاما يقولوا المثل الشعبي ابن الاصول لو
اطعمته الخبز فقط يصوم وقليل الاصول لو
اطعمته لحما يخون ولا عبره في المثل ابعد
من مائده طعام فاسووا الخيانات خيانه
الدين ثم خيانه الوطن والتراث الحميد يحكى
ان مطور جهاز الراديو الياباني سوني كان
فقيرا وكان بحاجه لدعم مالي لصناعته سافر
الى امريكا لعرض بضاعته على شركه كبرى
وافقت على شراء كل الكميه منه شرط وضع اسم
الشركه الامريكيه على المنتج بدل لاسم
الياباني فرفض صوني المحتاج لان حاجته
باسمه وانتماءه قال لهم اكبر بكثير من
حاجته للمهن
الحلقه انتهت وكل مونديال وانتم بخير الى
اللقاء 97
[موسيقى]
وحدفنا فيها الله عليها كفو يا